[Music]
for millennia if not since time
immemorial cultures around the world
have woven the sun into their
understanding of reality
to some ancient egyptians humans were
created from the sun god ra's tears
in viking mythology saul would cross the
sky with her brother the moon and in
doing so help humanity tell the time and
in one aboriginal australian story the
sun mother is sent on a mission to a
barren earth to awaken sleeping spirits
and give them form as both plants and
animals
and as science has advanced instead of
refuting these early notions as the
expanding of our horizons has cooled
time on so many other ancient beliefs it
has become clearer and clearer that
these myths are not so far from the
truth
in many ways
the sun
is
our god
on the most fundamental level the light
of our closest star warms the surface
and air keeping temperatures within a
narrow band so that water persists as a
liquid photosynthetic organisms capture
solar energy and convert it into their
own source of chemical nourishment
creatures who cannot produce their own
food in turn consume this converted
sunlight powering their cells without it
our planet would be a lifeless frozen
rock
drifting in oblivion
but more than just this there is
something deeper at play
for we do not only receive energy from
the sun's rays but we are made up of its
ancestors
remains
in ancient tales sun gods were sometimes
born from a more primordial deity the
aztec god whitser the pochle came into
being when his mother was touched by a
ball of feathers that had fallen from
heaven amitarasu the japanese sun
goddess was born from the left eye of
her created deity father izanagi
and just as these legends hinted a
lineage so our sun
is not the first
it was born from a stellar nursery
filled with gas the greater portion
collapsing under the power of gravity
until mata was dense enough
hot enough to shine
and it is from this attracted matter
that our earth was born
but what begot these vast latent nebulae
what created these scattered elements
that make up
us
our sun is in fact the latest iteration
of an epoch spanning cosmic recycling
what astronomers call a population one
star it descends from other now long
dead stars which transformed the matter
within themselves forging new elements
within their massive cores before
scattering their ashes in vast
supernovae
like the sons and daughters of solar
mythology our sun was born of an older
source of light but it was not simply a
clone of its parents its chemical
composition is very different to those
that came before a byproduct of its
ancestors life cycle while some of these
older stars must die to seed the
universe many of the less massive stars
from this generation persist
to this day
in the milky way population 2 stars
reside primarily in ancient clusters
outside of the galactic disk in what is
known as the galactic halo
and these stars too had ancestors of
their own receiving their constituents
from the most ancient suns with the most
pristine of ingredients the purest of
mixes
the yet to be observed population three
stars
the very first to be forged in the
universe
but again
these
were not the first cosmic cradles
of creation
for the ingredients of these enigmatic
giants were created in the very first
seconds of time
a brief instance when the entire
universe was hotter
than the sun's core
it was once said that we are star stuff
but that
is only half the story
the no hair theorem states that black
holes only have three properties mass
angular momentum and electric charge
nothing else can help differentiate them
and as albert einstein james clark
maxwell and max plank can attest
your hair or a well-shaped moustache or
beard can certainly help you stick out
in a crowd
henson razors have been kind enough to
support this video and they are the
cutting edge razor makers having
switched in 2020 from making aerospace
parts including for the actual
international space station and mars
rover they have taken that precision
expertise and need for perfection into
the world of razors
in fact they've convinced me to switch
from using my terrible electric razor
and i feel much better for it they're
also totally plastic free and should
last for decades and in the long term
because they basically never break they
should save you lots of money the blades
are only 10 cents and you can get them
easily on amazon meaning that it's
barely five dollars a year to maintain
so click on the link in the description
to get a hundred free blades with the
purchase of a razer and start having a
nice smooth face
thanks to henson for supporting
educational content
on youtube
[Music]
the year is 1782 a recent inductee to
great britain's academy of sciences the
royal society makes a claim that if true
would answer centuries if not millennia
of scientific inquiry
thirty-year-old james price had
discovered a way to turn base metals
into gold more specifically price
claimed that he had developed a white
powder that could turn a gram of mercury
into 50 of silver and a red powder that
could turn the same mercury into 60
grams of gold but unlike your
run-of-the-mill charlatan price had
performed experiments that backed up his
implausible claim with witnesses
while his fellow chemists at the royal
society remained unconvinced the
university of oxford saw fit to award
him an honorary medical degree for his
labors not explicitly for these
experiments but perfectly timed to
suggest they played a factor to the
greater public price had finally
demonstrated that alchemy was more than
magic
it was science
but as his fellow royal society members
demanded a replication of these
experiments for their own eyes price
quickly grew reluctant
he claimed the creation of the powders
was too strenuous on his health and that
the process would never be financially
profitable the value of the silver and
gold created did not exceed the value of
the materials put into making them his
reputation as an honorable chemist he
claimed should be enough for his peers
to take him at his word buckling under
the pressure in january of 1783 price
finally agreed to the royal society's
demands
of course price knew he was unable to
prove his implausible claim of alchemy
and so instead of turning mercury to
gold before the eyes of the gathered
fellows he drank a vial of concentrated
laurel water
and died
but the human desire to transmute one
element into another
did not die with him
modern tales of this desire tend to stem
from one man the so-called father of
nuclear physics
ernest rutherford
born in britain's new zealand colony in
1871 rutherford escaped the small single
single-teacher town of havelock at the
age of 15 eventually making his way to
the university of cambridge as the first
non-graduate of cambridge to earn a spot
as a student researcher not long after
the discovery of radioactivity
rutherford set his sights on the new
field and set up a lab at mcgill
university in canada to investigate
these mysterious new compounds
during one such observation in 1901
rutherford and his english colleague
frederick soddy caught a sample of solid
thorium slowly converting into radium
gas
sodi excitedly exclaimed the thorium was
naturally undergoing transmutation the
changing of one element to another to
which rutherford supposedly responded
for mike's sake sodi don't call it
transmutation they'll have our heads off
as alchemists
rutherford's aversion to the term aside
this was a huge moment
would the pseudoscience of alchemy edge
its way into reality by the 1920s
rutherford had demonstrated that by
bombarding nitrogen atoms with alpha
particles he could create hydrogen and
in 1925 to prove it once and for all he
tasked his student patrick blackett to
photograph the disintegration process
using a tool known as a cloud chamber
definitive proof that nitrogen could be
changed into oxygen blackhead had done
what james price could not
even though it wasn't silver or gold he
had intentionally turned one element
into another like it was awarded the
nobel physics prize in 1948
alchemy was possible if not what the
ancients had envisioned rutherford would
go on to say it is now possible by
modern methods to produce exceedingly
minute quantities of gold but only by
the transmutation of an even more costly
element
platinum
the 20th century had thus ushered in the
error of the subatomic atoms were not as
their greek name suggested uncuttable
elements became defined based not on
their overall mass but on their proton
count transmutation therefore merely
required that proton count to change
and such a feat was possible through
several means
[Music]
the first was through natural
radioactive decay which required no
human input whatsoever an unstable
nucleus would emit a particle thus
becoming a lighter element the second
was nuclear fission reactions wherein
human influence triggered an already
unstable atom to crack apart be that the
nuclear power plant or within the heart
of a nuclear bomb
and finally through the process of
nuclear fusion the combination of two or
more atomic nuclei a power which
humanity has yet to truly harness atomic
nuclei being composed of protons and
neutrons are positively charged and as
we learned from our first exposure to
magnets two positive sources of
electromagnetism repel one another the
closer to nuclei get the stronger the
urge for them to fly apart
but there is another force which can
come into play
the strong nuclear force binds protons
and neutrons together but its strength
drops dramatically beyond the edge of a
nucleus
therefore scientists must generate
enough force to push two nuclei close
enough together that the strong force
can take over in the core of our sun
this is achieved at the temperature as
low as 15 million degrees celsius
but on earth where we lack the crushing
pressure of the sun's continually
gravitationally collapsing matter we
need to get our fuel even hotter
at least by 10 times
a full century after the discovery of
nuclear transmutation today's scientists
are still pursuing the quest to imitate
the immense power source that maintains
our sun's billions of year lifespan and
created many of the elements that make
up the universe
the quest
for man-made
nuclear fusion
what is the source of the heat which the
sun and stars are constantly squandering
in 1920 english astronomer and physicist
arthur eddington posed this question to
his peers at the annual meeting of the
british association for the advancement
of science in cardiff
scientists of the day would answer the
question with gravity the collective
collapse of the gaseous matter from
which the sun is constructed would
generate a release of heat just as the
rocks and metals of the earth did a
leftover energy set in place when the
solar system first collapsed into its
various orbs
but these same scientists also knew that
answer could not be correct
the age of the earth and by extension
the solar system was already known to be
in the billions but at the rate with
which the sun shone it would have run
out of energy to release in a mere 20
million years eddington asserted that it
was mere tradition that kept this
hypothesis alive or rather not alive he
wrote
but an unburied corpse
instead he looked to the burgeoning
field of his contemporary rutherford for
a new answer a star is drawing on some
vast reservoir of energy by means
unknown to us this reservoir can
scarcely be other than
sub-atomic
energy eddington speculated that deep
within the sun hydrogen was turning into
helium and perhaps even heavier elements
and releasing energy in the process
indeed it was the stars themselves that
operated as cosmic factories
eddington estimated that through the
subatomic the sun could shine for 15
billion years while that estimate turned
out to be several billion years in
excess eddington's concept of stellar
nuclear fusion
was spot on and he went beyond proposing
merely how all stars shine
but what that meant
for humanity
the possibility that we could harness
nuclear fusion for the well-being of the
human race
or
for its destruction
[Music]
and over the past hundred years
scientists have worked towards at least
one of those fates
and it turns out the key to exploiting
the power of the sun
may lie in imitating its weaker sibling
brown dwarfs are often called failed
stars
they are so dim that they elude capture
but scientists believe that for every
true star in the universe there may be
an equal number of brown dwarfs
they are the intermediaries between gas
giants like jupiter and the smallest
stars failing to accrue the mass
necessary to begin the process of fusion
all true stars do specifically the
ability to fuse lone protons what we
typically describe as hydrogen into
helium but brown dwarfs are capable of
another kind of fusion
they mainly require a different kind of
hydrogen
deuterium is the lightest composite
atomic nucleus meaning it consists of
more than one nucleon like all hydrogen
it has one proton but bound to that
proton by way of the strong nuclear
force is an additional neutron
the abundance of deuterium depends on
where you search in earth sea water
there is approximately one deuterium
nucleus for every 5 000 or so hydrogen
nuclei composed of only one lone proton
known as protium
meanwhile in the atmosphere of jupiter
the ratio drops to 1 for roughly every
40 000 protium atoms far closer to the
true ratio of deuterium to protium
across the greater universe
and it is this deuterium that brown
dwarfs are capable of fusing with
protium this is because the presence of
that single neutron makes it slightly
easier for the nuclei to overcome their
mutual electromagnetic repulsion less
energy is required to fuse them together
as deuterium is naturally abundant in
sea water with only one liter of water
capable of generating the equivalent
amount of energy is burning 300 liters
of gasoline scientists on earth have
turned to this isotope as a possible way
forward into fusion technology
a type of alchemy where the most
valuable product is not the proverbial
gold made from lead not the helium made
from hydrogen but the energy released in
the process
price and his alchemist predecessors
would stand utterly confounded by the
machines we use today to transmute
matter
in one pioneering experiment
this is the modern version of his lead a
micro capsule of synthetic diamond
placed within a golden cylinder roughly
the size of a pencil eraser
this capsule is cooled to temperatures
just above absolute zero and placed at
the center of a giant spherical chamber
five meters to the inner edge
and it now becomes the target of
192 ultraviolet lasers
in far less than the blink of an eye
these lasers impart a pulse of invisible
energy to the capsule it disintegrates
its diamond coating inducing an
implosion to heat the contents inside
from all sides with so much intensity
that humanity can harness the vast power
of a brown dwarf
this is the national ignition facility
or nif in california
the most efficient way for humans to go
about turning hydrogen into helium fuses
deuterium not with protium but with
tritium tritium is as the name suggests
a third isotope of hydrogen one proton
two neutrons together they yield a
nucleus of helium-4 the most abundant
form of helium and a lone neutron and 80
percent of the energy liberated by the
fusion process is carried by that
neutron in august of 2021 a single nif
experiment fused roughly 200 micrograms
of deuterium and tritium to produce an
equivalent of 10 quadrillion watts of
power roughly 700 times the output of
the united states entire electrical grid
however it could only be sustained for
100 trillionths of a second meaning the
actual amount of energy it created was
just enough to power a light bulb
for six hours
still this experiment also claimed the
world record for the most
energy-efficient fusion reaction seventy
percent of the energy they put in came
back out
but for comparison this is only an
additional three percent above the
record set for deuterium tritium
reactions nearly 25 years earlier and of
course to ever be a source of power
it must exceed 100 percent
and so this nif experiment illustrates
two major hurdles scientists must
overcome before nuclear fusion can be
incorporated into humanity's power
generating infrastructure first a
reaction must produce more usable energy
than it consumes while the deuterium
tritium reaction is easier to achieve at
the outset than it is with other nuclear
fuels it is more difficult to convert
the byproducts of that reaction into
electrical power this is because the
vast majority of the energy generated by
the fusion reaction is carried away by a
neutral particle the second challenge is
that the reaction must be sustained for
sufficient lengths of time the
international iter project based in
france claims that it will be the first
project to create net positive energy
through nuclear fusion more specifically
the group hopes to produce 10 times the
amount of energy that they put into
making it however even if it succeeds in
its goals the energy it generates cannot
be captured
it will be up to yet more experiments to
harness deuterium's power
[Music]
it is clear that the deuterium tritium
reaction is not the perfect solution to
humanity's energy woes
[Music]
other kinds of nuclear fuel such as
helium-3 offer a cleaner alternative
while being more difficult to fuse
it is thought that our moon may hold a
treasure trove of this isotope built up
over 4 billion years of being bombarded
with individual nuclei ejected by our
sun assuming the technology can be
developed to create positive net energy
from such a fusion reaction the question
becomes whether or not certain areas of
our moon have helium-3 in sufficient
quantity to justify mining it as a
resource
we may yet see ourselves in the middle
of a second space race
as science continues its stare down with
the challenge of sustained nuclear
fusion humanity's modern alchemists hope
to one day recreate the processes stars
are capable of doing all on their own
processes that over billions of years of
death and rebirth have created nearly
all the elements we see today
but there was a time when stars were not
needed to fuse nuclei together before
brown dwarfs supernovae or even
population 3 stars there was a brief
moment
in which our entire universe
was a fusion reactor
[Music]
why would a person throw themselves
into a volcano
if you are the 5th century bc
philosopher in pedicles it might be to
try and convince your followers that you
are a god indeed the myth of
impediclee's death is just that
despite this surprisingly today he is
most well known for a singular proposal
originating in his poem perry physios
or
on nature as the title hints and
pedicles sought to identify the very
makeup of the universe only fragments of
the poem still remain but the thoughts
expressed have permeated western culture
well into modernity impedicles proposed
that every observable substance in
nature is composed of some combination
of fundamental substances he called
rhizomata or roots which he attributed
to four deities today scholars generally
translate these as fire earth ether and
water
plato then replaced the term roots for
stoichion which in english we call
elements
while aristotle would say that
empedocles was the first philosopher to
distinguish the four elements even
modifying the hypothesis to include air
other cultures had certainly formulated
their own versions of a similar concept
around the world humans were realizing
that everything we can sense in the
universe is actually when you break it
down made of more fundamental building
blocks
today we know of 118 elements most
frequently organized into a table which
shows the periodicity of certain
properties
the heaviest of these elements do not
exist in nature in any measurable
quantities due to their incredibly short
life spans and the vast majority are
made in the violent deaths of stars and
stellar remnants
through various different reactions
inside stars scientists have been able
to account for a lot of the elements
that make up our world but for many
heavier elements our sun is just not big
enough carbon and oxygen require a star
around half to four times the mass of
our sun whereas more than four times the
mass and the star confuse oxygen to
silicon and the creation of iron within
the core of a star more than 10 times
more massive than our sun acts as a
metallic death knell for its host a sign
of imminent supernova
so how can we explain a universe rich in
far heavier metals
one answer is in the brutal supernova
that scatters those elements across the
cosmos many heavier elements are
believed to be formed in the energetic
chaos of a star tearing itself apart
another is in slow neutron capture in
certain types of stars over thousands of
years
but yet another solution may lie in an
event even more violent
in 2017 the newly operated ligo laser
interferometer gravitational wave
observatory detected two neutron stars
colliding neutron stars are the densest
thing before a black hole the dead heart
of a massive star and using the
previously inaccessible medium of
gravitational waves ripples in the very
fabric of space-time ligo was able to
pick up the faint echo of a circling
pair's
final moments
but their detection was just the
beginning
the scientists were able to use
information from ligo to focus other
instruments on the killenova event that
followed the merger and through
re-analyzing the spectroscopic data in
the explosion detected a heavy element
strontium with the atomic number 38
proof that the most catastrophic events
in the galaxy are responsible for at
least some of the heavier elements
and so the explosive demise of these
stellar objects gifted us with the
various elements that make up the world
we know today but what gave them life in
the first place
what made up
the first
stars as with their heavier cousins
these primordial elements arose in an
instance of vast cosmic violence
the most energetic moment
in the history of the universe
the big bang
in the very first moments of our
universe a super fundamental particles
and anti-particles sprung forth from a
sea of energy with rapid expansion came
rapid cooling though temperatures were
still incomprehensible to mortal mines
10 trillion degrees celsius as the first
microsecond came to its end still it was
now cool enough for lone quarks to bind
together into composite particles we
call hadrons while we know of six
flavors of quark only two govern our
daily lives their names however fail to
convey their importance
they are merely known as up
and down
combine two up quarks and one down quark
and you have made a proton as all
hydrogen atoms are defined by a proton
count of one these were the first
hydrogen nuclei meanwhile each neutron
is born of one up quark and two down
quarks
together these two hadrons provided the
necessary ingredients for big bang
nucleosynthesis
the distant ancestor of every star every
planet and every life form alive today
the process of big bang
was first described in 1948 by then
graduate student ralph alpha and his
supervisor george gamoth the third
author on the paper hans beeta was added
by gamoff as a joke
the alpha beta gamma paper
was born
in this paper alpha predicted that the
incredibly high temperatures and
pressures found at the origins of the
universe could induce a multi-step
process of nuclear transformation
hydrogen the only element then in
existence would become helium for the
very first time and the first step in
this alchemical process was to
synthesize
deuterium the bonding of one proton and
one neutron into hydrogen's second
isotope while protons and neutrons had
existed in equal quantities when hadrons
first formed and could just as easily
transform from one into the other time
was proverbially waiting for no one
temperatures kept dropping making it
harder to craft neutrons
neutrons it turned out were ever so
slightly more massive than protons and
that extra mass meant slightly more
energy was required to create them
additionally neutrons were less stable
than their positively charged
counterparts as they continue to be
today powered by the weak nuclear force
a lone neutron will eventually undergo
radioactive decay becoming a proton
electron and anti-electron neutrino by
the time the universe was ready for
nucleosynthesis
there was only one neutron for every
seven protons a ratio which utterly
shaped the subsequent 13.8 billion years
of the universe's evolution while
deuterium could form just a few seconds
after the big bang it was still so hot
that if a stray particle of light hit a
deuterium atom it would break apart
scientists call this the deuterium
bottleneck and it meant that for at
least a time nucleosynthesis could not
move beyond a single element could not
progress onto or past the fusing of one
neutron and one proton
but somewhere around 300 seconds after
the big bang that bottleneck widened
deuterium could finally exist without
the threat of breaking down from a stray
photon and by then the universe was well
into the process of creating helium
there was however a ticking clock the
universe was cooling expanding just how
many elements could the universe birth
in the brutal heat of its own creation
once there was roughly one deuterium
nucleus for every 100 000 lone protons
they too engaged in nuclear fusion
reactions the process still used today
at least briefly by the brown dwarfs
hiding in our night sky
and it was from this union that a second
element finally arose
helium-3 nuclei constructed from two
protons and one neutron while hydrogen
can exist without neutrons helium cannot
its two protons exert a mutual positive
force that threatened to tear the
nucleus asunder as such there was no way
for two lone protons to create helium on
their own but with just one neutron
there was enough pull from the strong
nuclear force to overpower the
electromagnetic push a helium-3 nucleus
whether made at the dawn of the universe
or by a stray cosmic ray in the modern
day is
stable left alone it will persist
until the end of time
however the most abundant form of helium
is helium iv
two protons two neutrons
in this early universal forge helium-4
arises mostly from the union of a
deuterium nucleus with one of either
helium-3 or tritium and with helium-4
came the most stable composite nucleus
in all of existence
the most difficult to break apart
in nuclear physics it is the simplest of
the nuclei we call doubly magic
if the early universe preferred the
proton over the neutron it preferred the
helium-4 nucleus over all others safe
proteome the march of times therefore
dictated that in these first few minutes
most of the protons and neutrons in the
universe that began the process of
nucleosynthesis became trapped inside
helium-4 and went no further
together with the overall density of
matter at the time the ratio of protons
to neutrons restricted just how much
helium could be made if mata were more
compact at the time of big bang
nucleosynthesis
more helium would have formed
perhaps so much helium the least
reactive of all the noble gases that
little to no chemistry may have ever
happened throughout the rest of time
we often say that the early universe was
75 protium and 25 percent helium 4
specifically when measured by mass
photons neutrinos dark matter and so
forth are not incorporated into this
statistic but it is an important one
as it is also the composition
of the very first stars
and these are the population three stars
which astronomers continue to hunt for
[Music]
but hydrogen and helium are only two of
the 180 elements in our modern periodic
tables
where did the rest come from
the universe
keeps cooling
fusion
continues
next up three protons this is lithium in
big bang nucleosynthesis two isotopes
are created lithium-6 and lithium-7 the
latter in greater abundance beryllium is
next with four protons but it is
unstable decaying into lithium in an
average of 53 days and beryllium-8
meanwhile exists for less than a
billionth of a second indeed no isotope
composed of eight hadrons is stable
and so here nucleosynthesis
hits another bottleneck
with fewer heavy nuclei in abundance and
with ever-dropping temperatures it
becomes almost impossible for the
universe to create an isotope with at
least nine
hadrons if any boron carbon nitrogen or
oxygen were crafted it was in such
limited amounts that there is no record
of the universe having done so
finally 20 minutes after the big bang
the nuclear furnace that spans the
entire observable universe
dies
only four elements exist and only three
exist long enough to see the first stars
shine
hydrogen helium and a trace amount of
lithium
it would be at least 200 million years
before the universe had another
opportunity to seed itself with heavier
elements when blazing spheres of
hydrogen and helium compressed their
cores with sufficient force to achieve
the temperatures
long missing
but it is through those stars or rather
their descendants that we must piece
together the state of the universe at
this ancient time
and in doing so scientists have
discovered a mystery that lingers at the
heart of this lineage of celestial
bodies
an imbalance that threatens our
understanding
of the entire timeline
[Music]
in 2013 astronomers made an impossible
measurement observing a star which had
been an occasional target for at least a
century they finally pinned down its age
or did they
at first glance this star appeared to be
older than the universe
14 and a half billion years old
and it was located only a mere 109 light
years away in our own solar neighborhood
its designation
[Music]
hd140283 but in popular media it became
known by the biblical name
methuselah
of course it was far more likely that
there was some kind of error made in
either the measurement taking or in the
fundamental understanding of how these
measurements correspond to a star's age
than it was that the ancient star was
born before the known universe and
indeed when the team accounted for the
various uncertainties in their
measurements the minimum possible age
became
13.66 billion years
methuselah was not older than the
universe
further research published in 2021
suggests the star may be even younger as
young as 11.5 billion years old
calculations completed this past decade
still suggest a wide array of ages
though all within the first billion or
so years of the universe
so we may never know its true age but
its composition does tell us something
crucial about cosmic history
[Music]
based on the abundance of metals in
methuselah's atmosphere astronomers know
that it was not one of the very first
but instead formed soon after stars from
the first generation died
stars like the big bang before them go
through their own version of
nucleosynthesis both during their lives
and at the moment of their deaths this
means that the abundance of metals be it
iron or oxygen increases amongst all
subsequent generations forcing us
further and further away from the image
of a universe before any stars at all
population three stars with
metallicities as near to zero as the
universe allows gave birth to population
two with metallicities of roughly 0.1
percent
and through their lives and deaths they
eventually in turn gave birth to those
stars classified as population
one with metallicities in excess of one
percent
methuselah appears to be one of the most
ancient population 2 stars and it is
this generation which astronomers have
been forced to study to try and confirm
what models predict
the original elemental abundances after
big bang nucleosynthesis ended
and the composition of the ever elusive
population 3 stars
astronomers also look beyond individual
population 2 stars in their attempts to
extrapolate back to even more ancient
days
they turn to the least massive
irregularly structured dwarf galaxies
that contain them
with less mass there is less hydrogen to
collapse and form stars so due to their
relative lack of star formation these
minuscule galaxies tend to have the
lowest metallicities and so they are the
closest proxy to the abundance of
elements in a time before
stars
measuring a galaxy with near zero
metallicity implies the amount of helium
has not been altered through stellar
nucleosynthesis
the abundances of hydrogen and helium
mimics the ratio found in the first half
hour of the universe
hundreds of millions of years before the
very first stars
indeed there is little disagreement
between the abundances of hydrogen
including deuterium and helium-4 in
these only slightly less ancient days
compared to the primordial levels
predicted by mathematical models
lithium however
is a trickier matter a mystery
science
has yet to solve
stars it turns out are particularly good
at destroying any lithium inside them be
it what they formed with or what they
made along the way to heavier metals
thus they obscure the story of how much
lithium was created in the big bang's
metaphorical forge
nevertheless by narrowing in on how
readily lithium is both created and
destroyed observations of population 2
stars in particular the oldest hottest
stars we can find in the milky way's
halo can still provide estimates
but these estimates do not match what
other analyses imply
according to current astrophysical
theory the amount of lithium crafted
after the big bang as well as every
other primordial element is ultimately
dependent upon a single variable the
ratio of photons to protons and neutrons
at the moment big bang nucleosynthesis
began
by looking at the cosmic microwave
background which reveals the oldest
light our telescopes will ever see
astronomers can measure that ratio and
therefore predict according to the known
laws of physics how much lithium-7
should have been created
but that expected value is roughly three
times greater than what is actually
observed
astronomers have given this unique
discrepancy a name
the cosmological
lithium problem
and there are three possible solutions
[Music]
the first looks to the stars the
measurements we take of them and the
equations describing their inner
workings only the outer layer of a given
star can be observed so some of the
apparently missing lithium may be
concealed at a greater depth or used up
in the fusion process that our current
physics cannot depict in full but
astronomers are also not directly
measuring the abundance of all lithium-7
some must be inferred given the local
temperature however determining the
temperature of any one spot within a
star is rather more complicated than it
might seem at first glance so a small
deviation from the true temperature
manifests as a much greater error in the
amount of lithium astronomers believe
they must add to what they already do
detect
a second solution is found at the
nuclear level specifically the ease at
which different nuclei interact with
each other bind together or break apart
may not match our current understanding
for example since primordial lithium-7
is created by the decay of beryllium-7
if it were actually harder for
beryllium-7 to form than our models
suggest or less likely to decay into
lithium-7 that could explain why we
observe a lower quantity of primordial
lithium
a team of researchers considered this
possibility in 2015 but their analysis
created an even starker divide between
observed quantities and theoretical ones
and finally it may be that our theories
that describe the nature of reality
paint an inaccurate picture
our underlying assumptions were not just
big bang nucleosynthesis but for all
astrophysical processes are incomplete
at best
the theoretical abundance of all the
primordial elements stems from
cosmologists understanding of the
fundamental processes of reality the
four fundamental forces of gravity
electromagnetism and the strong and weak
nuclear forces the expansion of space
the properties of subatomic particles
it also depends on the state of the
universe in those early moments its size
temperature and density and how rapidly
each of those is changing indeed we
already know that our models are
inaccurate in specific matters such as
the fact that neutrinos actually have
mass or that dark matter almost
certainly exists and is likely made from
particles which remain unaccounted for
in the standard model
exotic particles which existed at the
dawn of time but no longer or still
existing particles we have yet to
discover could have tipped the scales in
a process we are as of yet blind to
or perhaps it is the universe as a whole
that is not what we think it is
the cosmos is assumed to be homogeneous
over large scales
our position in the universe is no
different no more special than any other
position stretching across billions and
billions of light years from each world
alien astronomers would measure the same
overall structure
but what if that weren't true
if our region of the cosmos was in fact
special say a little less dense than the
overall average the measurements we take
may be biased
only time of course
will tell
with more advanced telescopes more
sophisticated computer systems to crunch
the numbers at finer details scientists
may one day resolve this primordial
lithium problem perhaps it is simply a
matter of our current methods being
insufficient to fully capture the true
nature of the universe or perhaps the
true nature of the universe is itself
something other than we imagine
and so we continue on
to try and comprehend how our universe
went from an energetic soup of a handful
of fundamental particles to the vast
cosmos we see experience
and take part in
today
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching
and we'll see you
next time
[Music]